et on va accueillir à présent florence
portelli pour les républicains florence
portelli qu'est maire de taverny bonjour
et bienvenue
bonjour florence portelli alors on a vu
vous avez 61 députés les républicains 74
si on y ajoute lui dit et les divers
droite ça veut dire qu emmanuel mac on
ne pourra pas gouverner sans vous
écoutez moi je pouvais pas me réjouir
que le pays souhaite ingouvernable je
veux pas me réjouir qu'on ait réussi
enfin qu'il ait réussit rigueur
m la quatrième république au sein de la
vème république sur sa catastrophique et
il pourra pas gouverner tout court c'est
hyper inquiétant alors sans nous mais ça
veut rien dire sur quoi pourquoi quel
programme qe vision de la société et
puis à pattes le parlement c'est un
moment gouverne aussi avec les
territoires parce que vous parliez tout
à l'heure des territoires mais
territoire ont été profondément méprisé
pendant cinq ans et je vous assure que
les collectivités territoriales ont
peut-être aussi un rôle à jouer dans la
compréhension du pays et s'est fracturé
maudite il pourra pas gouverner tout
court ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire
qu'on s'oriente vers une dissolution et
les français vont devoir revoter j'en
sais rien mais quand vous avez des
partis populistes qui ne rêvent que
d'insurrection et qui disent que
finalement dans une vie tradition
marxiste finalement que le pendant de la
du rapport de force honte aux logiques
de l'état c'est finalement le rapport de
force dans la rue et qui en plus ne se
sentent plus enfin bon bref je fais ce
que je veux dire donc ça se met ça va
être compliqué mais avec les
républicains quand il ya des projets de
lois qui vont dans le bon sens pourquoi
pas évidemment si ça va dans le sens du
pays il faut évidemment aller voter mais
pour ça il faut déjà avoir l'humilité
d'écouter j'ai entendu hier olivier
ferrand dire je ne comprendrais pas
qu'il ne vote pas si ou ça ça démarre
très très mal il va faire de l'humilité
de la part de tout le monde parce
qu'aujourd'hui le score c'est une
responsabilité collective oui mais
notamment des républicains est ce que ça
doit pas est ce que cette nouvelle donne
du monsieur qui était au pouvoir oui
ne doit pas mener les républicains à
revoir un peu leurs positions qui
étaient de dire pas d'accord de
gouvernement
h vous aviez parlé de fond pas d'accord
de gouvernement sur le fond qu'il n'y
avait pas de projet pendant la
présidentielle vous avez entendu un
débat de fond moi pas non mais la magie
d'un grand mes oreilles j'essaie encore
de sonn'automne faisait surgir là par
exemple chez vous jean françois copé
hier soir il a appelé il a rappelé j'ai
envie de dire parfois qu'il dit un pacte
de gouvernement avec les maniaques ouest
il faut le faire c'est sûr que c'est pas
un ennemi demande sur le fond il ya des
sujets précis sur lesquels les
républicains veulent agir aujourd'hui et
pourrait agir elle a en passant un
accord avec magna mac ont été noyés des
sujets sur lesquels je n'ai rien entendu
et je considère que c'est des sujets
fondamentaux vous avez sûrement de
parler des retraites par exemple la
retraite à 65 ans il peut y avoir des
points d'achoppement n'y a pas de
problème mais c'est pas ça qui fait un
projet de société sur l'éducation quel
est le projet de société de ce
gouvernement pour moi l'éducation c'est
la priorité j'ai rien entendu j'en sais
rien sur la culture ils ont même pas
parlé une seule fois de la culture sur
l'écologie c'est quoi de la vision de ce
pays dans les 10 20 prochaines années
oui mais les audoises augis fermé la
porte avant même avant des solutions
fonds et
vous mes le fonds pour vous c'est des
logiques d'appareil me suis en train de
vous parler des vingt trente prochaines
années pour simple pourquoi normale et
design essaye de jouer d'un véritable
pacte de gouvernance et de réformes
commune avec la majorité mais là vous
êtes en train de parler de réformes qui
interviennent dans un dans une vision de
la politique extrêmement ponctuels moi
je suis en train de vous parler des dix
vingt trente prochaines années comment
des gens redeviennent maîtres de leur
destin en impression d'avoir la maîtrise
de leur destin dans un monde qui leur
échappe de plus en plus je vous assure
que c'est un chantier très vaste sur
l'incident dans lequel on a aussi notre
part à 30 parce que je ne pense pas
qu'on ait donné nous mêmes les réponses
dont celle de jean-françois copé a tort
quand une équipe un peu d'ambiance j'ai
rien contre jean françois copé tant
qu'ingénieur au fond vous avez cas mais
est-ce qu'il a changé
un pacte de gouvernement avec des gens
qui pendant la campagne présidentielle
ont tout fait sauf présenter un vrai
projet pendant les cinq ans il ya même
eu des des revirements en permanence
quelle est la colonne vertébrale de
manuel macron enfin sincérité je ne sais
pas ce que pense le président de la
république sur plein de sujets médiane
moi je vais pas vous parler d'accord sur
du rien alors il ya des chantiers à
mener sur le long terme mais aussi des
urgences notamment le pouvoir d'achat
c'est le premier test qui va arriver à
l'assemblée on connaît les principales
mesures proposées par la majorité s
quand les wii ou bouclier tarifaire
revalorisation des retraites du rsa dgde
gel du point d'indicé des fonctionnaires
et veut tout et rien dire bah c'est du
concret pour beaucoup de français est-ce
que vous on est attendus du très court
terme en plus avec la dette qui a galopé
je ne sais pas jusqu'où ils pourront
aller sincèrement mais ce que ce texte
par exemple à mes chocolats ses parents
si des textes sur les ailes mais bon
c'est pas un jour adhérer alors oui mais
on sait pas ce qu'ils auraient dans le
texte est un moyen un sujet pareil par
exemple sur lesquels je suis ok je suis
extrêmement attachée c'est la
participation est un vieil un vieux
poncifs gaulliste que par un salarié
d'une entreprise qui participe à son
succès
retouches quelque chose parce que
justement il a peu contribué au succès
commun voilà je suis plus attaché la
participation qui est déchets brian
dimension participation sur les
dividendes versés aux actionnaires aux
salariés oui par exemple va j'attends de
voir quelle forme ça va prendre pour le
moment ça a été très très flou comme
disait une ville de notre bord qu il ya
du flou il ya un loup martine aubry pour
ne pas les citer s est pas vous
elisabeth banque doit parcourir ou est
ce qu'elle peut rester premier ministre
avec les résultats d'hier c'est dire est
ce que je vais vous dire mais je pense
qu'on s'en fout complètement je pense
que c'est pas le sujet parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya le premier
ministre d'une majorité qui n'existe pas
c'est pas un sujet de vrais sujets
encore une fois c'est qu'elle est
qu'elle est la traduction de cette
désespérance citoyenne vous avez parlé
des scores divers et variés mais aussi
au score de l'abstention qui est
croissant alors évidemment c'est pas de
2017 mais c'est quand même le deuxième
record entre guy m'a sinistre en matière
d'abstention rentrer d'abstention un
vote éclater un vote protestataire
aussi désincarné parce qu'avec cette
histoire de non cumul et quinquennat les
gaines des gens qui aujourd'hui vote
pour des personnes sans trop savoir
quelles sont leurs parcours j'ai vu dans
mon département j'avais un truc était
très marrant quand vous regardiez les
affiches le nom d' affiches qui avait
papa ou maman à côté du candidat donc
macron le pen zemmour mélenchon cta il
est très très peu de gens en fait qui se
présentait sur leur parcours proc sur
leurs convictions propres et massa en
dit long sur la décrépitude de la vie
politique actuelle donc il faut aussi
redonner de l'incarnation et redonner
sens et revient au cumul des mandats
je sais pas si sa priorité mais si on
revient au cumul des mandats il faudra
dans ce cas d'apple a freiné et éviter
un cumul d'indemnités parce que des gens
tout de suite la suspicion vu le climat
délétère d'un canot n'est que c'est pour
gagner de l'argent pas pour gagner de
l'argent
m désincarné je vous assure que ça
contribue aussi à la montée des
populismes on ressent un peu désabusé
dans l'industrie aujourd'hui sur la
situation politique de la france subit
fidh je vais pas vous faire du baratin
parce que
voilà vous le dira c'est merveilleux on
a 60 heures et quelques sièges c'est
génial on a limité la casse tout va bien
non ça va mal le pays va mal oui mais
vous et votre parti porte des idées
porte des valeurs porte des propositions
est ce que c'est pas le moment madaule
et de les mettre en avant et donc mettre
en avant d'aller encore plus loin et là
où je suis prête à faire tout à fait
d'accord avec vous je n'ai pas désabusé
je suis lucide pour faire la langue de
bois je dis justement que vu l'état de
la société actuelle ces moments au
contraire d'avoir l'audace de l'espoir
et d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans ce
qu'on propose et d'année n'ont pas sono
court terme comme le font en général des
partis politiques notamment de
gouvernement médaillée dans des
perspectives dans la société pour la
société de demain qu est-ce qu on offre
à nos enfants qu'ils aient la place de
la france dans le monde qu'est l'europe
veut peut-être pas forcément celle
d'aujourd'hui et des tas de sujets qui
doivent être remises en cause est-ce
qu'on peut enfin faire de l'éducation un
pilier une priorité dans ce pays est-ce
qu'il faut pas revenir sur le collège
unique je vous assure que des tas de
sujets de société sur lesquels on n'a
pas pu débattre et qui serait il serait
peut-être temps déportée loin devant
mais est ce que pour faire entendre ses
sujets de fond dont vous parlez et ne
vous mens pas d'un rachat c'est pas une
question de chef mais je crois que vous
voyez là vous êtes enfin vous êtes vous
faites votre métier ce qui est bien
normal mais on est en train de parler à
chaque fois deux logiques partisanes le
problème c'est pas la reconstruction de
la droite brasser la reconstruction de
la république dans ce pays quand vous
avez l'abstention du populisme silo
c'est comment on refait nation et bien
pour sabah il ya un vaste chantier
idéologique à mener ça demande beaucoup
mais c'est voulais pas le faire avec le
mac os que le problème c'est pas la
reconstruction la droite pour que vous
soyez nouveau il ya un problème global
je suis d'accord avec vous il faudra
beaucoup d'humilité beaucoup de travail
et actuellement je pense qu'on en est
qu'aux prémices
d'une question qui va se poser très vite
cette semaine qui doit présider le
groupe l'est républicain à l'assemblée
nationale je considère aussi que les
gens s'en fichent complètement que c'est
pas un sujet donc ce sera sûrement
quelqu'un d'autre et c'est un sujet pour
votre parti politique pour la liste
portée dans les cinq ans qu'ils savent
ou encore ces questions là c'est un
sujet derrière les personnalités il ya
des idées il ya des projets ainsi fait
la différence quand même entre des
républicains est nulle ou
horizon ensemble ce que vous voulez
c'est qu'ils ne se sont pas compromis
donc quelle que soit la personne qui
sera la tête du groupe la ligne
idéologique est quand même là même c'est
quand même l'avantagé patron d'un groupe
est quand même parti du côté la majorité
présidentielle le patron d'un groupe à
damien abad oui mais justement il est
parti c'est très bien c'est très clair
est-ce que vous avez vu nombre d'une
compromission pendant la campagne des
législatives entre les républicains un
autre parti politique non et d'ailleurs
c'est tout à leur honneur parce que
c'était encore plus risqué donc comment
à partir du moment où la ligne est
claire quel que soit le président de la
présidente ce sera un président qui aura
une légitimité très tant mieux laurent
wauquiez a après un quasi carton plein
dans sa région en amont ben beaucoup de
députés a l'air plus que en 2017 est ce
que ces résultats enfin le successeur de
christian jacob
ben si je considère que c'est pas le
sujet du moment que ça n'a encore une
fois mais christian jacob l'a dit a dit
qu'il allait quitter la table et il va
bien faire il faudrait trouver sort et
sur quelle negri met justement en est la
question c'est pas tellement qui va
succéder c'est qu'est ce qu'on dit aux
gens que l'on pourrait le lien entre les
fractures sociales par exemple ça veut
dire qu'il faut plus de social il faut
aller vers galère doivent s'orienter
vers une femme et elle chute au revers
et la rive droite droite non c'est pas
une question d'être droite droite parce
que la droite droite peut être social je
vais
un mouvement proche de philippe séguin
philippe séguin n'était pas un homme de
gauche mais il défend d'un gaullisme
social ne veut pas dire être une droite
mode ou édulcorée mais c'est vrai que la
droite ne sait plus s'adresser aux
classes populaires elle ne fait plus
s'adresser aux jeunes elle ne sait plus
s'adresser aux gens qui ont un sentiment
de désespérance elle ne sied plus
s'adresser non plus aux français
d'origine immigrée elle a un discours
qui stigmatise ans et c'est un discours
en plus excusez moi mais qui est corner
reese ans qui est même parfois
limités donc au lieu de stigmatiser les
uns et les autres à droite elle doit
s'ouvrir s'ouvrir ça veut pas dire se
prostituer idéologiquement ça veut dire
au contraire revendique un discours
républicain qui acceptent le plus grand
nom en étant ferme sur nos valeurs sur
la laïcité sur un ordre du mérite tout
ce que vous voulez mais ça ne veut pas
dire pour cela qu'il ne faille le faire
en copiant des extraits - ayant un
discours excluant et méprisant il faut
remettre de la dignité au coeur de notre
société et pour ça il faut aller
s'adresser à des populations qui nous
ont fui regardez dans les détails des
sondages qu'elles sont l'étranger la
population qui ne votent plus pour nous
c'est très instructif merci beaucoup
florence ortelli
[Musique]